[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes mi nombre nicolás soy
constructor y ambientalista previsión
una mezcla bastante rara malla queso soy
una amante naturaleza y también soy un
buzo desde el año 2011
y les quería compartir uno de los museos
que más me ha marcado mi día fue un
museo en que tuve la suerte de bucear
con el pez más grande del mundo el
tiburón ballena y exactamente cómo está
en esta foto de abajo a contraluz y
lleno de peces que lo acompañan
esta imagen acá es que la recuerdo me
pone la piel de gallina porque realmente
marcó mi vida con la naturaleza y me
conecto profundamente algo que se tiene
hasta el día de hoy
la verdad una experiencia mágica y que
tú ya recuerdo y preso que ya le vengo
las de naturaleza de medio ambiente y
más que es hoy día vengo de irrigar tres
mitos sobre el cambio climático el
primero es que el cambio climático no le
va a afectar a ti ni a ti ni a mí
el segundo
es que el aporte que yo puedo hacer o
que usted puede hacer es tan chico si en
verdad no cambia nada
y el tercero es que tal vez yo no me
siento tan verde o tan sustentable como
para poder hacer algo
para hacer esto para agregar primer mito
le voy a pedir a todos que cierren sus
ojos hagan el salón y lo que también el
vídeo que serán sus ojos también en su
casa
y que imaginen como para mí fue el
bucear con el tiburón ballena el momento
más importante y más lindo que han
tenido naturaleza donde estaban con
quién estaban qué temperatura hacía yo
lo sabía
que estaban haciendo
en ese momento tan lindo ahora tómenlo y
proyectan en el futuro en un futuro con
una naturaleza destruida que ya no
funciona en una situación catastrófica
ahora les pido que ahora el ojo
le quiero cantar que esta situación
está en cuenta regresiva quedan 15 años
para poder llegar al límite del
calentamiento global de 15 grados
celsius este calentamiento global está
comparado versus la temperatura pre
industrial estos fines del 1800 y en
2017 superamos la regla del 1°
si seguimos como estamos ahora vamos a
superarla arriba del 15 el año 2034
en esta época yo tener 50 años y
pretendo y quiero seguir buceando y no
sé si voy a poder seguir luchando con
tiburón ballena o con cualquier animal
ya que no sabemos cómo va a estar el
océano
hoy día estamos enfrentando la crisis
climática y ecológica más grande que se
ha visto en la historia la humanidad
estamos enfrentando la sobrevivencia de
la raza humana y todavía la gente actúa
como si nada le quiero presentar a un
grupo de científicos que el que estudia
estos datos esté libre cc.oo el panel
intergubernamental de cambio climático
de la onu en un grupo científico que
estudia el cambio climático y reporta a
todos los países medidas de mitigación
medidas de resolución de crisis
climática y si las entregas como
políticas públicas para que ellos puedan
ocupar y pasar datos de ciencia a
políticas públicas para poder resolver
esta crisis
es tan real y tan cruda sobre todo en
los países más pobres seguro científico
se está acelerando y profundizando cada
vez más antes durante la cop 21 en 2015
en parís se habla de la barrera de los
dos grados celsius pero se dieron cuenta
el año pasado en 2018 de que esto era
demasiado y hay que bajarlo 1,5
es por eso que
hoy día se alarmante estamos en una
crisis y hay que comportarse como tal
mito número 2
mi aporte va a ser muy pequeño así que
no hacen la diferencia sobre esto quiero
contar la historia una historia una niña
una historia niña que hace un año nadie
la conocía
ella
junto con un grupo de compañeros de
curso del colegio dijo oye hagamos cosas
para poder enfrentar la crisis climática
y si la prioridad es falta faltan los
viernes a clases falta lo viene a clase
e ir al parlamento al parlamento sueco
de estos en suecia con un cartel blanco
con letras negras que decía
acción climática crisis acción tribal
la cosa es que esta acción tan simple
como ir a protestar gente un parlamento
con un cartel una niña sola de 15 años
se ha convertido en el movimiento más
grande y revolucionario sobre el clima
en la historia de la humanidad esta foto
es del viernes pasado en santiago donde
ha sido donde fue la marcha más grande
sobre el cambio climático que existió en
chile
esto no solamente las en chile vaso en
todo el mundo más de cuatro millones de
personas marcharon por la crisis
climática eso como la población de costa
rica- marchando todo el mundo para decir
que hay que hacer algo que esto está mal
que hay que revertir esta situación
entonces si una niña con un cartel se
convirtió en el rostro de esta
revolución ambiental todo desde nuestros
distintos lugares podemos aportar no es
necesario ser un científico del ipcc no
es necesario trabajar en la onu no es
necesario trabajar en el gobierno para
poder hacer algo sino que todo de
nuestra área podemos ayudar
el tercer mito es que yo no soy
suficientemente ambientalista
sustentable como quieran decirle
la verdad yo en el colegio la
universidad nunca me consideré
sustentable ni ambientalista no me
importaba mucho cambio climático ni
siquiera saber nada de eso en esa época
pero todo cambió cuando me convertí en
bus como le mostré la imagen el comienzo
el buceo me conectó con la naturaleza a
un nivel mucho más de lo que yo me
imaginaba me enamoré de las cosas
pequeñas grandes medianas de lo molusco
del arrecife de coral
y de ahí me cambió la percepción
recuerdo perfectamente contigo de usar
algunas partes y de encontrar con los
manchones de basura y tenis competente
entre la basura para poder bucear y yo
le pregunta a la gente el barco oye pero
porque donde llega esto no llega del mar
y se queda que un tiempo después se va
después vuelve otro macho ni así
la raíz de ese problema que se
incrementa más y la vez que yo usé con
el tiburón ballena me hayan dicho que
los años anteriores cada vez que había
muchos y cada vez hayan menos ya esta
altura puede que ni siquiera existan en
ese lugar ya que una especie de
extensión
qué hice siendo constructor sigue el
traje varios años cinco años como
contexto civil y siempre tuve el bichito
verde desde que me puse a usar y que no
lo tengo que hacer algo para ayudar al
medio ambiente que me fui estudiar un
máster en medioambiente y cuando volví a
chile dije quiero hacer algo mayor
planeta
y no sabía qué hacer estaba inventando
una cosa aquí y allá y me junté con un
amigo de la universidad
que tenía ni idea de poder hacer algo
que los recibió construcción empezamos a
amar al conjunto
y realmente nació la idea de poder hacer
un aporte en mi ambiente desde ese
sector
le presentó el problema de los residuos
de construcción en chile o estos
representan un tercio de todas las
basuras olvida generar el país son más
de 6 millones con heladas al año en un
problema gigante e invisible esta foto
justamente es de un botadero de
escombros que existe aquí en valparaíso
y si lo ven es una quebrada con árboles
hasta entremedio y rellenan lleno de
escombro dentro sin ningún control es un
problema grave y nadie lo está
enfrentando y donde nosotros dijimos
aquí podemos ayudar y creamos la startup
creamos un negocio que buena empresa lo
cual no vengo a vender sela no vengo a
hacer negocio aquí
pero habría como sea
y una aplicación como spotify y netflix
rápido donde uno elige dice oye yo creo
que será mi recibo y dice ya voy a
reciclar fierro clic voy a reciclar
madera voy a reciclar una y reciclar
cartón a 7
tal como nosotros pedimos comíamos
rápido creemos que sea fácil y rápido
esto lo mismo le hacemos fácil la
gestión de residuos a la construcción la
hacemos fácil la gestión de residuos
responsable la construcción algo que
antes nunca se había hecho
estamos conectando a la industria más
sucia y más contaminante de chile y el
mundo con el mundo la sustentabilidad a
través de un puente tecnológico algo que
nunca antes había hecho
pero va a poner un poco más en concreto
les voy a contar la historia la manera
esta es una de las primeras
recolecciones de madera que hicimos
una empresa constructora nos pidió atrás
de la obligación un camión para reciclar
madera y allí hay dos viejos cónsules
dice en la contra
hay dos viejos cargando palos desde el
suelo hace un camión no hay nada
complejo ni nada los del mundo
y ya están diciendo a tengo que cargar
palos junto es a mí vega
quien lo llevo nosotros de una empresa
constructora conectándose con una presa
de las fuerte que esta empresa
transporte lo hay en una planta de
reciclaje manera donde van a limpiar
esta manera la aplicar chilito la
naranja con orgánicos y van a convertir
en compost luego se compuso incluso
puede volver a la misma obra a ocuparse
los jardines
quien lo que es esto para mí en esta
economía circular es gestión responsable
residuos es conciencia por parte de la
empresa constructora es un aporte es un
cambio de mentalidad tremendo
a la fecha
tenemos valorizado más de 300 toneladas
de residuos de construcción lo cual
entre nunca es hoy se ha hecho porque ni
siquiera se les pasamos la cabeza estoy
atenta al peso de dos ballenas azules
disculpa que seguido las ballenas pero
me encantan
maya que 700 toneladas hemos disminuido
el impacto ambiental de la industria
construcción en 500 toneladas de co2 es
un poco ambiguo también pero ella lenta
a sacar 140 autos de circulación en un
año o dejar de quemar 250 toneladas de
carbono es un impacto real en el impacto
tangible y un impacto al medio ambiente
directo y eso nos tiene terriblemente
felices y orgulloso
anteriormente también hemos ganado
varios premios hemos ganado seis premios
con chile uno afuera vamos a competir
por otro la pregunta ría nueva york
más que todo eso quiere decir que
nuestra startup más que una empresa de
más que un rut más que un buen negocio
es una causa es la causa de querer hacer
la industria construcción más verde más
consciente y más responsable es una
causa que recién está partiendo es algo
nuevo y estamos invitando a todo el
mundo que se sume porque es necesario
que todos se sumen para poder enfrentar
la crisis climática
detrás de esto hay un gran equipo yo
solamente soy la cara que lo represento
y un equipo que está completamente
comprometido con el medio ambiente y
estar aquí acompañándome así que se lo
agradezco chilló pero ha venido más que
comprometidos con la empresa están
comprometidos con el mundo para poder
ayudarlo igual que yo nos levantamos
todos los días contentos de poder
trabajar en algo que está siendo un
aporte al mundo y el medio ambiente
desde que pasó todo esto y estoy
trabajando dedicado 100% a salvar el
planeta como digo yo muchos mis amigos
empezaron a molestar y empezaron a tirar
tallas también en la familia y me dicen
capital planeta
y yo a ja happ y si yo me reía también
que habita el planeta aquí que tanto
detalla buena hasta que llegue un día un
amigo y me dice hoy único previsto
reciclando texto en redes sociales me
encanta lo que así dice es que yo
también voy a reciclar en mi caso y dije
wow aquí hay un cambio pasó algo
yo también sé capital planeta mismo
entonces ahí me cueste dije si yo soy
capitán planeta como es mi amigo y él
también sé como capitán planeta este
bichito está funcionando está pasando un
cambio en la sociedad está pasando un
cambio en mi grupo amigo está pasando un
cambio mi familia ahora me llama también
recicla y eso me tiene también muy
contento
las cosas que tienen una tremenda
oportunidad y ha tenido una tremenda
oportunidad será un punto inflexión
entre un antes y un después sobre
nuestra conciencia por el medio ambiente
este año somos los anfitriones de la con
es el encuentro sobre cambio climático
más importante del mundo y va a ser aquí
en chile a fin de año 196 países
malone europea van a venir a chile
justamente a comunicarse a conversar a
sentarse a decir cómo resolvemos la
crisis climática entre todos ya que no
existe una solución ni una persona ni un
país que lo vaya a resolver
espero de corazón que resulten las
negociaciones y que los países se
comprometan a disminuir su impacto
ambiental y que sean ojalá todos carbono
cero de aquí al 2050 o antes
es una tremenda oportunidad tanto para
chile como para el mundo para poder
tomar lo como 'mantienen después de como
no hemos comportado
en esta imagen muestra justamente el
corazón de lo que es la con 25 que es
comunicar trabajar en equipo
colaborativamente
esta foto muestra el equipo de gestión
de residuos de las 25 donde nosotros
somos parte y somos el software oficial
de gestión de residuos de la cocina
y la organización y en este que hemos
conversado y queremos ser la cob más
limpia de la historia nunca antes estaba
medido y se ha gestionado residuos de
construcción de una copa porque la com
se construye durante un par de meses ya
empezó ya luego esas el evento y luego
se saca y se desmonta todo lo que se
levantó
desde nuestra startup estamos viendo
todos los recibos que se han generado a
la fecha llevamos valorizado más de 10
toneladas vamos viendo el evento y luego
el del de montaje en resumen vamos a ser
los primeros en llegar y los últimos en
irnos para asegurarnos que todos los
residuos que se puedan priorizar se
valoricen para disminuir el impacto
ambiental del evento lo más posible y
puede mostrarte que acá en chile también
estás haciendo cosas buenas
todo esto las 25 este cambio con ciencia
es justamente un llamado un llamado a la
gente a que empiece a pensar y actuar de
otra forma activar el pensamiento
crítico justamente
expreso que les pido y día tres cosas
la primera es tomar conciencia yo lo
hice a través del buceo usted lo puede
hacer a través de su vida en la casa en
el trabajo a través de sus hijos a
través de una película que dieron un
documental hay mucha forma algo que les
toca el corazón y que les pegue ese
bichito verde que a mí me pegó cuando vi
el tiburón ballena
una que también consciencia tiene el
paso 2 que dan el automático que hacen
tomar acción
uno cuando tiene consciencia tomar
acción es muy simple cuando yo le digo
los viejos en la obra hoy hay que
reciclar madera para mí la agencia que
recibirá manera presión oye si tú
reciclar la manera tus hijos van a poder
disfrutar la playa porque el mar nos va
a estar ácido en el futuro iban a poder
bañarse le vaya para tener un futuro a
tus hijos y ahí lo que jo me miran dicen
aunque esto tiene un sentido voy a
hacerlo porque realmente tiene un
impacto en el planeta en el futuro y
hacer las cosas con un sentido por
detrás es muy diferente hacer lo
obligado porque el jefe le está diciendo
por último el tercer paso es inspirar
inspirar
viene de la mano con la acción ya que
cuando alguien ve a un amigo o familiar
haciéndolo con su casa por ejemplo
reciclando le pregunté hace ahí porque
estoy reciclando por equis motivos y
empieza a dar vuelta ese año también
podría serlo y la inspiración más
simplemente por el hecho la acción no
necesario
no se hace una charla como lo que está
haciendo ahora pero es una forma de
inspirar y me encanta hacerlo hay muchas
formas de hacerlo y le va a ir saliendo
automático si que empiezan a tomar
acción en distintos campos de su vida
y es por eso que ahí entra el llamado se
hace de estas tres cosas si empezamos a
cambiar todos juntos como sociedad ya no
va a ser solamente yo el capitán planeta
sino que vamos a estar lleno de
capitanes planetas y capitán las
torretas que tomen acción por este mundo
que estamos en crisis en una crisis
alarmante todos pueden aportar desde su
lado todos pueden ayudar todos pueden
hacer una diferencia todo puede ser una
revolución un cambio drástico incluso
como louis obrera
es por eso que hoy día
los llaman a reflexionar
ya que de parte del artista e charla han
pasado ya 15 minutos 15 minutos que nos
quedan menos de este reloj son 15.000
con menos de buena actuar antes de que
llegue la catástrofe climática estos 15
eventos de reflexión tiene que convertir
en acción después de salir de esta sala
después de ver este vídeo
y por eso que les vengo a dar este
mensaje
estas charlas típicamente terminan con
un mensaje de esperanza al final para
que todos sean felices tranquilo y gana
dhabi esta charla me contento
lamentablemente yo no voy a hacer eso
hoy día de ser club pues un aguafiestas
porque me imagino que alguna vez han
escuchado la frase yo aporto con mi
granito de arena quiero aquí hacer la
pregunta que les pido grande la mano
quien ha dicho de su boca la frase yo
aporto mi granito de arena
delante de la uefa
bastante gente
lamento decirles con un granito de arena
estamos como estamos con un granito
arena el mundo se está quemando hoy día
es necesario que aporten con un puñado
de arena con un saco arena con un camión
de arena para poder darle más tiempo a
nuestro mundo y poder asegurar nuestro
futuro
[Aplausos]
[Música]